winter storm Elliott may have long
passed over much of the U.S but Arctic
air lingered on Christmas day over
two-thirds of the country we are in a
war this is a war with Mother Nature and
she has been hitting us with everything
she has since uh the late hours of
Thursday into Friday Saturday and now on
Christmas morning and this will go down
in history as the most uh devastating
storm
in Buffalo's uh long story history
the polar temperatures not only created
the phenomenon of lake effect snow in
the Northern Great Lakes Region but also
ocean effect snow in Maine on the
Atlantic coast the principle is the same
cold air moving over warmer water
creating intense storms
high winds meant white hat conditions in
some areas even where the snowfall had
stopped many remain trapped in their
homes homes where power outages are
expected to continue due to the blocked
roads it's not just power lines down
even though there's a lot of that it
actually is substations are frozen and
they now need to bring in equipment to
repair the substations
to get them back online
there were reports of some feeling they
had no choice but to attempt to drive to
so-called warming stations as their
homes grew ever more frigid despite
advice that driving in whiteout
conditions could lead to death either
from a crash or being stranded in the
cold and some did find themselves
trapped in their cars for two days
fatalities have been reported in
Colorado Kansas Oklahoma Nebraska New
York and other States bodies have been
found in cars and on snow Banks others
in their homes after Emergency Services
struggled to arrive in time
would-be air passengers continue their
determined push to try to complete
Christmas travel only to find another
day of thousands of flight cancellations
and delays but a thought is forecast
over the next week the longer it stays
this cold the more other systems across
the state could be challenged but the
good news is it's getting warmer and
it's getting warmer each day there still
isn't an accurate accounting of just how
damaging this storm system has been but
it's clear this was yet another in a
series of extreme weather events in the
U.S where authorities have been
struggling to cope
she ever tendency Al Jazeera